what's going on guys guardians of the
galaxy number one box office smash of
the year I love the movie and I was
thinking could guardians of the galaxy
happen in real life
today real scientists are gonna answer
all my dumb questions and what you're
about to find out may shock or prove me
to be an idiot
first I'd like to say welcome back
doctor it's great to be back
oh it's fantastic to have you so we're
talking about guardians of the galaxy
have you seen it I have not wow that's
nice man of science that's what my
students said when I asked them
yesterday dr. Clifford Johnson how large
is our galaxy in terms of the visible
stuff the actual stars you've got
something like a width of a hundred
thousand light-years think of it in
terms of numbers right we have our own
star that we're going around there our
life aside it is called the Sun that's
right and then we are talking about a
give or take maybe a hundred billion of
our stars like our Sun just in our own
galaxy alone impossible I think it's
possible I think we kind of go that to
be a fad okay you went that way how long
would it take me as a guardian of the
galaxy patrol if I don't say I had to do
my my nightly rounds too long for your
lifetime like so if I was security guard
working overtime you're dialing an
edition a hat what it's it's not gonna
be a nightly shift so they got to the
other side of the galaxy in the movie
probably in like the movie was like 20
years after they took him from a thing
they they have they have something that
can help a little bit
which is what's called time dilation
moving them moving at that speed they
will actually age more slowly according
to physics than say people staying here
on earth that will help them a little
bit I'm not you you're not gonna reduce
a hundred thousand years down to 20
years oh but it would help them a little
bit from the point of view of the people
on earth though so are you saying when
they come back to earth to help out the
Avengers the Avengers will all be dead
fraid so except the immortal one out
yeah Kevin Feige does not want to hear
that in one scene a star Lord Peter
quill is floating in outer space with
only a mask how long would a man last in
outer space if he had just a breathing
apparatus on his mouth
no suit no some very long you'd be
exposed to a lot of radiation and cosmic
rays and things like this and it's
probably wouldn't be good for you you
can actually survive for a little bit in
space but the worst idea is to be
breathing any air if you do what you
might instinctively do which is breathe
in and hold your breath and then you go
out into the low vacuum of space that
air is gonna be trying to get out it's
gonna rupture your lungs Oh No so I
don't know what that breathing devices
but if it's giving him air and then he's
breathing normally his lungs are in
danger so if you just have a breathing
apparatus it wouldn't be very long but
there are ways so what if it's a pretty
pretty slick sweet-ass mask with like
two like red eyes uh probably much of a
difference
what if okay what if you're wearing a
leather duster um you'd look cool when
you're dead so if we are forgiving maybe
also project something that protects his
lungs because if it doesn't he's in
trouble if he's in a cumin spaces so
maybe it does yeah that I'm saying that
okay yeah if you had a cassette tape for
twenty years and just played it over and
over again how long would it take for
the tape to wear out I'd bet against it
going on for twenty years
uh I I would say with constant playing
console um can I give you a number but I
just know how my own cassette tapes and
I still have some okay you're right
Jericho evidence doctor my empirical
evidence is by now that tape would not
be playing so well wrong it lasted okay
plants trees living things of course
good answer
now how far are we from science creating
a conscious responsive tree that would
take a lot of work that would take a lot
of work given that we don't understand
what consciousness is yet I know I'm
awake and talking and
thinking yeah but how do you know that
I'm conscious how do you know I'm not
trying to computer program talking to
you with programmed responses okay don't
scare me doctor yeah I mean bring in
here to scare me and give it a night not
exactly I'm not scaring you I'm hoping
that I are getting you excited about
that puzzle you are scary thinking that
like you're like a robot man
biologically speaking could there be an
alien tree
I might allow that okay I might allow
you think that's possible well first of
all I think it's more cool than than
possible but there's a small likelihood
I can imagine that
well guardians the galaxy is cool that's
a given so I hear okay it's pretty sweet
you should see it okay how far are we
from making a talking raccoon I have a
running battle with raccoons in my
garden pretty much every night
especially during the spring gotcha and
I communicate with them all the time but
not speaking are you communicating
telepathically with raccoons
I'm not telepathically mostly with water
cannon and anything I can throw at them
when they're trying to dig holes in my
vegetable patch so it's good
old-fashioned communication nothing
sophisticated what we could do maybe
what's going on with rocket is that they
have indeed ways of interpreting signals
in the brain and then maybe there's a
hidden device that's then projecting
that in terms all maybe cuz yeah Jedi's
all yeah all those um bolts and
everything in the back something so may
wind it's something yeah like a
universal translator from you know that
other you know Texas Instrument what
else thinking but I go with that iPhone
app uh if you like could a man
impregnate a raccoon oh no could a
raccoon impregnate a lady no human lady
no how do you know um I'm pretty sure
that the wiring doesn't work like that
way yeah there is an infinity stone that
is capable of destroying an entire
planet do you have anything like that
no okay I mean there are incredibly
powerful sources of energy in the
universe yeah and we know about them
yeah but that small that compact here on
earth as far as I know no I mean if you
think about it in your clear bomb isn't
that big in volume and yet look at the
destruction destruct
that it does so there may be possibly a
way of packing that much energy into
something in a very very dense way into
something very very small I'm down with
that I think that that you know okay
so light makes sense I don't know how to
do that that I don't think anyone does
but right might make sense on the
Galactic scale that still small potatoes
compared to the kinds of energy sources
you can find like black holes for
example are incredibly dense sources of
power if you can manipulate them in the
right way they're not usually that small
though
if a man were to make love to a black
hole mm-hmm what would happen probably
not going to come back from that
experience yeah it looks like it once
you go black never come back yet again
we've proven without a shadow of a doubt
that science eludes me we want to bring
those scientists back to debunk
something else what would you like to
see us break down is it the future
onsters NIC cages hair let us know in
the comments section below if we use
your idea we will send you a screen
junkies t-shirt how about that I'm Hal
Rudnick thank you for watching and hit
me up on Twitter bye-bye is it realistic
for one to go back in time by going 88
miles per hour in a DeLorean flowing
through a flux capacitor I don't know
until you tell me more about how that
thing looked I just explained how it
worked
they still haven't told me enough